Io rubo e la verità io sono orgogliosa
di essere donna ladra non mi interessa
se c'è una denuncia c'ho mille denunce
ho rubato Ieri ho rubato Oggi cosa ti
interessa Vuoi sapere cosa ho rubato
Oggi ho rubato solo 5 portafogli Due
telefonini E sai perché per colpa di
Striscia e Spaventa i cittadini non
siamo mica mostri noi non siamo mica a
terroristi mica buttiamo bombe Peccato
vietato rubare adesso no vuoi chiamare
polizia ti ama sì tanto già lo sanno
peruviano è il nostro lavoro Sì è il
nostro lavoro dobbiamo rubare cosa vuoi
fare Vuoi tenermi qui non puoi è
arrivato Sì va bene non rubo più per
adesso Fammi andare Basta Sei una merda
fai schifo merda